une civilisation qui n'est plus capable
de se défendre elle-même est menacée
menacée de l'extérieur et peut-être
d'elle-même de l'Intérieur or le fait
est que l'Europe occidentale aujourd'hui
doit sa défense sa protection sa
sécurité aux États-Unis et c'est là tout
de même un symptôme de décadence le 17
octobre 1983 il y a exactement 40 ans
c'est l'un des plus grands penseurs
français du 20e siècle qui nous quittait
Raymond Haron professeur à la Sorbonne
et éditorialiste au Figaro laisse
derrière lui une réflexion du actualité
brûlante sortons des idéologies pour
chercher la vérité soyons capable de
défendre notre liberté face au
totalitarisme ces convictions rém Haron
se laissait d'abord forgé à l'École
normale supérieure qu'il intègre en 1924
et où il se lit d'amitié avec d'autres
grands intellectuels de son temps comme
Jean-Paul Sartre ou George kangilem son
crédau ne jamais laisser le cœur dominer
l'esprit il refuse ainsi de se laisser
séduire par l'utopie communiste et place
la liberté individuelle comme valeur
suprême une lucidité qui le démarque de
nombre de ses contemporains d 193 3
Raymon hararon fut aussi l'un des
premiers à comprendre que le pacifisme
ne serait d'aucune aide face à la montée
de l'Allemagne nazi et que les
démocraties devraient se résoudre tôt ou
tard à reprendre le chemin des arbes la
défaite française de juin 1940 le
marquera d'ailleurs à vie mais refusant
de perdre espoir et persuadé de
l'aptitude du peuple français à endurer
les pires souffrances pour sa cause il
gagne l'Angleterre la même année pour y
prendre la direction de la revue la
France Libre là encore cet esprit libre
trace son chemin et refuse de s'aligner
sur deux Gaules critiquant la dérive
sectaire de ses partisans il renonce à
cond l'armistice signé le 22 juin 1940
par le maréchal Pétin et rejette la
chasse aux sorcières voulue par certains
goulistes traître les collaborateurs oui
traître les tenants de la Révolution
nationale certainement non ceux qui
regrettent aujourd'hui que l'épuration
n'ait pas frappé tout le monde se
conduisse en fauteur de guerre civile
c'est après la guerre en 1947 que le
penseur rejoint le Figaro article après
article il poursuit sa lutte contre le
mythe de la Révolution et l'obsession de
la gauche française pour les régimes
communistes moins l'intelligence adhère
au réel plus elle rêve de révolution
virulant mais toujours élégant le
philosophe refuse de renvoyer dos à dos
l'URSS et les États-Unis et défendra
toute sa vie la démocratie libérale
contre le totalitarisme qu'il soit brun
ou rouge s'il est conspué par la gauche
Aaron n'a pas que des amis à droite il
fait notamment sensation en publiant en
pleine guerre d'Algérie son ouvrage La
tragédie algérienne où il juge
inéluctable la prochaine indépendance de
ce pays et invite les autorités
françaises à la préparer le taux de
croissance démographique est trop
différent des deux côtés de la
Méditerranée pour que ces peuples de
races et de religions diff puiss être
fraction d'une même communauté vient
ensuite mai 68 une révolte qui le
révulse autant qu'elle l'inquiète dans
cette protestation contre la société de
consommation est-ce qu'il n'y avait pas
aussi une révolte un peu puérile des
enfants gâtés de la bourgeoisie qui
possédent déjà les biens qui méprisaient
les biens qu'il posséd dans les années
qui suivon est d'ailleurs convaincu de
ce qu'il appelle sans détour mais sans
jugement moral la décadance de
l'Occident découvre guerre de raisons
d'optimisme quand je regarde devant moi
les Européens sont en train de se
suicider par dénatalités les peuples
dont les générations ne se reproduisent
pas sont condamnés au vieillissement et
du même coup guettés par un état
d'esprit d'abdication une lucidité qui
ne rimait toutefois pas chez lui avec
cynisme considérant que l'histoire n'est
pas totalement déterminée à l'avance
Raymon Haron a toujours cherché à
souligner l'importance des individus et
donc de l'action politique sur le cours
des événements une partie de la société
française ne veul B ce que j'aelle